[Music]
this week on
forward Ultra pass simplifies verified
data exchange it's it's it's it affects
everything what the problem we needed to
solve was how do we air this high value
private information in a way that
simplifies people's lives empowers them
this is going to change how people
businesses and governments engage with
one another it is not a question
question of will this happen it's just a
question of how fast does it happen when
it's comes time to vote in a primary or
a referendum or an election you open up
your mobile voting app which is going to
verify that you are you by way of your
Board of Elections credential and now
you can vote from your phone
[Music]
what
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast the founder and CEO of ultra
pass what the heck is that a good friend
of mine Eric star welcome
Eric hello Andrew good to be with you
today how are you doing I'm doing great
uh so you and I have known each other
for years back from my Venture for
America days uh you were in sustainable
Finance something very very wholesome
raising money to do good for the world
uh what is your background so people can
quickly get up to speed yeah well well
thanks for pointing that out because it
wasn't always that wasn't always the
case um you know my early days of my
career actually started out in in U
launched a hedge fund which I would say
is not really um doing good uh but but
and in so doing uh there was always a
part of me that wanted to you know give
back to the community and I ended up
outside of my professional life
volunteering a lot in my community um so
I always had that balance of of doing
good with uh doing work um and early
days in that hedge fund world I I
started what was what is now called
Quant we use math to uh identify
opportunities in capital markets and I
did that for a number of years uh 15 and
uh exited out of that uh at the uh early
days of 2008 you know I had been you
know really a Pioneer in in that space
it didn't ex Quant didn't exist in when
we launched in
1992 and it became this really big thing
and I remember I was at a conference end
of 07 be Sterns that just had obviously
blown up and I remember there was a
bunch of hedge fund guys there and we
all had the same trades on and I uh
decided at that point that was like
Epiphany it's like time to move on time
to time to do something else um so I I I
got out of that space some of my
investors had been with me for 15
years and I made a purposeful decision
to get into private credit I knew that
there was a credit crunch coming we kind
of all did at that time and I also
wanted to lean into how can I help
people as we do that and um I had
partners and we launched another uh
Venture that focused on providing
Capital to small businesses to help them
grow um and have a positive impact on
the economy and we partner with the
federal government to do that and our
public private partnership and ran that
for uh a number of years until we sold
it my role there as a partner was again
to bring the math to bring the
discipline to figure out how to use
technology to make things easier for
small businesses to access capital and
that was again early
08 uh over the next number of years that
became was now what's now known as ftech
but at the time it wasn't called that um
so uh I saw really that whole evolution
of technology and finance over the the
subsequent uh uh 10 years or so uh we
sold that business back in uh 2017 I
stayed on for a period of time um and
but I've always been at really the Nexus
of data technology and uh doing good um
and that is certainly true now here at
uh at Ultra pass so you must keep an eye
on the markets I can't help but think
that a lot of people think what's going
on right now seem is really really weird
um you know you have 13-year low in uh
number of houses being sold last month I
think like it seems like because
interest rates are really high and
people like oh I can't afford a mortgage
uh and but then people who are already
in homes like oh snap like you know I I
would need a new mortgage so I guess I
can't
sell there's this um massive problem in
uh commercial real estate that I've
actually talked about on the podcast
so those are two massive massive um out
of whack uh markets that that seem like
they're destined for some kind
of uh correction um the the stock market
uh you know people have different
opinions about um so I know you're not
in it all the time like you once were um
but I'm sure your head can't help but
consider some of these situations like
you know do you have any thoughts on
what what's going on out there in terms
of the markets and and the rest of
it yeah I do of course right uh uh never
short on opinions but really the the
lens through which I I look through
which I think is what you know has
really has been the backdrop of our
relationship over the years is it's not
just about having opinions it's about
being a problem solver right and so yeah
I have opinions but like take the take
the housing crisis or the housing it's
not a crisis the housing situation where
it's stuck right I'll give you two Sol
solutions that would unstuck the housing
market um mortgage portability and
mortgage assumption right because we
know if I have a if I have a mortgage on
my home for 30 years at three and a
half% right I'm stuck I can't sell my
house and buy something new because of
the higher interest rates but if I can
bring my mortgage with me wow to a new
home wouldn't that be cool or what if I
could assign my loan to the new buyer of
my house that's more assumption or
mortgage portability so there are
solutions out there to unstuck the
market now who wins in that well
everybody well if you're the bank that's
made the loan well clearly you want to
get repaid because you can lend it back
out at
7% which you can't because nobody's
taking those loans but right you you
could put terms on it it's like all
right if you're bringing your mortgage
with you well then the loan to value on
that new house has to be better than it
is today I mean so there's ways to do
this where not only do buyers win and
sellers win but also the banks can win
so there are solutions to to the
mortgage crisis the commercial real
estate's a little bit more complicated I
don't really see a path forward right
now uh in let's face
it work from home or return to office
whatever you want to call it is is is
challenged right we don't I don't know
what the what the future holds I do know
that more people want to work from home
but the data now suggests that working
from home is not the most efficient uh
use of people's time um from a
productivity standpoint and then you
have the issues of of how do you train
people remotely and how do you Foster
interpersonal skills and how to learn
how to work with people and for people
when you're not in the same zip code so
I think there were challenges ahead for
commercial real estate there are
probably really Creative Solutions I
just don't have any in that space yeah
no I mean that's just going to be a
rough go but mortgage portability and
mortgage
assignability um
genius are people actually looking at
doing that I mean we don't know how long
this Market's going to be stuck I I I
will say I think it's going to have very
very bad nasty consequences beyond the
fact that right now people can't afford
homes people aren moving I mean those
things are not good um but are are
people are banks actually looking at uh
doing what you're describing cuz it's a
great set of ideas I mean you know just
hey like mortgage goes with you I don't
think so I I haven't you you're the
second person I have not heard us I
haven't heard a whisper like this is the
first conversation I've heard of either
even those Concepts but they're they're
so common sense I I I've only socialized
this with uh with a friend of mine last
week um when I was thinking about
because he had brought up the whole
mortgage challenge that uh that we're
facing and you know those two those two
solutions seem to make a lot of sense
I've socialized it with him and I'm
super excited about man someone should
should take them and run with them based
on this look at this we could solve a
giant uh housing problem from
this pod because of my genius friend
Eric y let's do it I'm a little busy
right now but heck you know what I ideas
are free somebody wants to run with it
give me a call yeah someone else to run
with that man I mean you definitely have
your hands full so yeah Ultra pass born
in part of a tweet I put out there um
right as Co was hitting where I said hey
would it be great if the government knew
who we were and uh we each had a unique
identifier and then uh if for example
that there was a pandemic um and they
wanted to send us money they could do so
really really easily and
straightforwardly and so I put that out
in the world and then you ran with it to
the point where now it's real uh which
I'm super excited about um so talk about
how you came to ultra pass and what
Ultra pass is sure so I'll tell you the
the origin story you mentioned that
we've been friends for a long time and I
got involved in your presidential
campaign and right around the time uh so
let's put things in perspective I sold
my company in October of 2017 now I was
still an employee there I had an earnout
in those kinds of things but if you do
the math you know in November of 2017 I
got a phone call so here I am I've sold
my company but I'm still working and
then my friend calls and says hey I'm
running for president and I said let's
do it not president of What Not
president of what you know I appr let's
do it right let's do it so you know for
the subsequent couple of years I was I
was in it I was promoting I was Raising
I was yeah man you were in Iowa was
glorious oh that was yeah I called it
the the last Iowa caucus at the time no
you weren't wrong yeah so right yeah I
can tell stories about that which are
which I think you're you you're your
listeners would appreciate well we'll
come back we we'll come back to that
later it's a real life story about the
Iowa caucus so anyway you pull out of
the race it's February I believe of 20 y
2020 and and I'm thinking I got all this
time back right what am I gonna do with
all my time and I'm living in New York
City and uh you know what happens in a
few weeks Co and it's raging and I
remember watching the news uh on TV from
my apartment and there are you know
people crying
because city's been shut down people
lost their jobs they're applying for
unemployment insurance they go online
and the system's crashing and those was
lucky enough to submit an application
well they have to verify with a phone
call and the lines are busy for days so
they're crying there like they're like
through no fault of my own I cannot earn
money and now the system that's there to
support me in the time of need
completely fails
and that was this Epiphany moment it's
like why do we accept I'm watching the
news I'm like why do we accept such
terrible system experiences when we're
dealing with our government and that was
really the the the impetus and I I put a
deck together on all the things I want
to I want to fix and yeah it was like
applying for unemployment or filing for
taxes or voting from your phone um those
are the things I I really wanted to
solve for and um so I put this deck
together and you know you're tweeting
out about a a citizen portal and I asked
you to share a little signup sheet a
little form Google Google form to see
who's interested to join me in figuring
out how do we solve these problems and
it was through that Google form um I met
my now co-founder Dave poule so he and I
have been focusing on on this problem
from uh middle of
2020 um and at the time we had no idea
how to solve these problems but as you
know as a as a as a problem solver in
technology and data I figured well can't
be that
hard you know people are putting you
know we put a man on the moon in 1969 we
could probably figure this out uh so
what we started was we started
researching to try to understand why
these problems exist um and then we can
start to craft
Solutions so what we Learned was that
the the real the reason why engaging
with government is so terrible is
because government's not like this one
thing right so right now Andrew you're
sitting in New York City yeah so you're
in New York City you're in New York
state and you're in the United States of
America those are three completely
separate governments yep now the
NYPD has information on Andrew Yang the
board of elections has information on
Andrew Yang and the IRS has information
on Andrew Yang now those three
departments cannot by law share your
personal information with one another
they're in different jurisdictions but
even if they were in the same
jurisdiction they couldn't share
information privacy laws you can't share
private information without consent so
given this siloed nature of government
and the fact that you know cuz what's
the arum well the right hand doesn't
know what the left hand is doing I don't
understand I did it over here now I got
to do it again well that's because of
all the silos that have uh existed and
and over the over the years we've just
we've we've collected an enormous amount
of data that is locked away in these
bureaucratic vaults behind firewalls
right and it's really hard to get at
it's better I don't want to make this
like sound like well that was a bad idea
it wasn't right right we used a hodge
podge that grows over time you know yeah
yeah it's better than like your
information in a piece of paper in a
file cabinet I mean that's useless right
but it does create from a user
experience digitally challenges because
that right hand doesn't know what the
left hand is doing so what Ultra paath
so what we learned from uh what we
learned was the problem was we have the
siloed information that creates really
challenges when it comes to customer
experience and I'll I'll share it like
the alternative right where Amazon right
Amazon knows everything you've ever done
with Amazon it knows what you like to
buy how you like to pay for it where you
like to have it shipped it might know
some things you didn't do with Amazon
that's exactly right right so by having
that information about you they can
deliver this amazing customer experience
government can't do that right and I
don't and As Americans where we value
Freedom we don't want government knowing
everything about us I know I certainly
don't well we we we're used to Amazon
and Google and uh facebook/ meta um
maybe Apple uh now knowing everything
about us we're totally comfortable with
that because we're like oh good this
will lubricate my
transactions they'll s me stuff but but
but if you put government in there then
people would become very very Le
uncomfortable to your point yeah no it's
an interesting it's an interesting
dichotomy right we're willing to give
our information away for you know free
Wi-Fi but you know so long as it's not
the government getting it uh there is
absolutely I mean I've had a lot of
conversations about privacy and it's
like oh people don't care I'm like well
they kind of do care um it just it's
about a tra it's about the trade-off and
with government the trade-off is
negative imagine running for president
and wanting to share what you
experienced in a way that's entertaining
edifying and maybe even a little bit
scary that's the last election out in
bookstores now a novel about an
independent presidential candidate a
journalist with a massive story and what
the heck could be our nextlast election
check it out at andrewyang.com
[Music]
yeah I mean we should care we're getting
pummeled uh and conditioned in a
particular way I mean this is obviously
I was making this point on the
presidentials like hey guys like maybe
our data should be ours maybe we should
be able to bargain collectively etc etc
um but just commenting the the fact that
we do have a different attitude uh
toward government even though government
is what should be um the system that
helps us in the time of need that you're
describing and when people were trying
to get their unemployment benefits um
that often was through state
so the federal money went to the states
and then the states couldn't administer
it in some situations uh and that played
out not just here in New York uh that
that played out all over the place oh
yeah there are so many issues that arose
as a result of coid I mean it was
estimated I think the number was $281
billion of fraud in 2021 sure because we
we had to we had to open up these
programs to get money into the hands of
people and as you know Andrew right you
know right historically there's been a
tradeoff between speed and
accuracy all right and again it's
historically true if you want to move
fast sometimes you know you gota you
gota you got to break a few things and
what ends up happening is well we got to
get money out quick so what happens you
know you get Bad actors that come in and
say I'll take some and they took a lot a
lot so anyway we have this uh we have
these challenges uh privacy is another
one I agree with you
uh we should care the US is a unique
place I mean it's the best country in
the world um but when it comes to
privacy and data we're behind other
parts of the country the world totally
you know we don't have California's got
CA but Europe really has gdpr and people
are really leaning into gdpr it's where
you can you own and control your data
and you can say I don't want you to have
it anymore and pull it all back we don't
have that yet in the US people in the US
everyone once in a while you find
yourself on a European website and then
all of a sudden it's like hey all this
data stuff pops up and at first you're
like what's going on here but then you
realize oh wait it's just a European
site sure I'll accept whatever you're
doing so anyway so what you you asked me
like how do I get here and what do we
what is ultra pass so what we learned is
or what the problem we needed to
solve was how do we share this high
value private
information locked away in these
Stylo databases in a way that simplifies
people's lives empowers them gives them
agency over their own information and
absolves the custodians of that data
from privacy breaking privacy laws like
how do we do that if we can solve that
problem then maybe we can unlock the
data in ways that simplify people's
lives and that's what we began to build
um that's what Ultra pass does what we
are is a digital trust
platform that
facilitates the sharing of verified data
now it's words what does that actually
mean say I I'll I'll use an example and
what we do is not limited to governments
and programs because what we do is it's
going to affect everybody
everywhere um but verify data
exchange which is what we provide is
going to become ubiquitous around the
planet and to give you a sense of scale
Shopify
simplifies e-commerce right and
e-commerce is freaking big right Ultra
pass simplifies verified data exchange
it's it's it's it affects everything so
so what do I mean I'll give you an
example in
healthcare um and what I want what I
hope is some of my examples resonate
with your listeners and they go Ah
that's such a problem we can fix that
the answer is yes so let me give you
some examples so if you've ever needed a
second opinion from a doctor you have to
get your medical records from the first
person to the second person yep and
health records are really sensitive
private information so the doctor one
can't just send it to doctor two right
what you have to do is go to doctor 2
fill out a form and the doctor let says
I want you to get my records the doctor
then faxes it yep fax to the first
doctor it may go through it may not go
through if it goes through somebody's
got to pick it up and then they got to
send your
records however they send
them
mail electronically who knows to the
second doctor and you hope it gets there
before your
appointment that's friction that's
painful so what does ultra pass do well
we don't actually do this today but we
I'm interested in doing this you you
have the capacity to do it yes exactly
we want to work with the electronic
medical records companies what we could
easily do is um Dr a issues your medical
records back to you similar to how an
airline issues you a boarding pass
and then you when you set up when you
when you create your appointment with
the second doctor and says hey do you
have your medical records yes will you
share it with us yes they will request
from your phone your medical records and
now you share the records with the
doctor it happens all at the time of
appointment done now what's just
happened the doctor gave you your
records you then gave it to the second
doctor that's verified data exchange now
there's a lot of tech technology that
goes into it couple of important points
one the individual the patient can't
tamper with the information that they're
moving there it's their records but they
can't change them it's it's tamperproof
two the recipient the verifier the
second doctor can trust the information
you've sent because cryptographically
they can confirm that that your medical
records were given to
you by a certified doctor so now they
can trust who issued it and they can
they can know you didn't tamper with it
now they can trust the information
they've received without having to go
back to the original doctor and say hey
did you send it
that issuer holder
verifier
relationship is what we promote that's
what we call this verified data exchange
model
issuer holder verifier we make that
happen in every industry every in any
place any use case where a holder needs
to move in their information from point
A to point B in a verified tamper proof
way that's what we
do this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no no one can see it you know
it's the way to go because a bunch of
big companies say hey all of you
high-end consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com
today that's
expressvpn.com yangang and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
gang
so do you use the blockchain because
that's one of the things that people
associate with a blockchain is being
able to
verify uh this kind of transaction we
can uh but we don't have to so first of
all what we don't do is we don't put
your medical records on blockchain we
don't do that the use of blockchain
would be where the cryptographic keys go
um so when that verifier wants to
validate that it was issued by a
certified doctor right so we could use
blockchain to P put the the uh the keys
on chain you don't have to so if we're
working with a
government and they have
a.gov web
pager we can put the keys in the.gov
because it's not going away you know you
wouldn't put them necessarily on a on a
domain that you know might change
tomorrow but you could use it could be
just purely web 2 or it could use
blockchain um and introduce this notion
of of web 3 but you don't have to use
blockchain uh sometimes there are and we
were brought into situations where they
where it's like they're brought in
because they want to do something on
chain um and sometimes they just need to
solve problems and whether it uses the
blockchain or not uh is is irrelevant um
one of the big case use cases we're
working on now now you know the idea of
using blockchain has come up but they
have problems to solve big ones and um
we can solve them okay so so you have
this verified data exchange uh platform
um so number one can you describe a few
other use cases aside from my health
data which makes perfect sense to me um
and it could be actually lifesaving or
super handy um but what what are some
other use cases that we could get
excited about potentially I'll give you
two one would be in the area of uh Civic
engagement so if you've gone through the
process of applying for SNAP and getting
food stamps you go through you provide a
lot of
information um to the to the program uh
inperson interviews it's you know it's
it's
challenging at the end of that process
what we can do is hook in with that
agency and allow them to issue back all
the information they collected from that
applicant and provide it back to them to
their phone and now when that individual
goes and applies for public housing
rather than go through the entire
process from the start providing all the
same information they just share their
information the application gets
instantly approved not just filled out
but approved because all the the
information has already been vetted by
snap and public housing can determine
the validity of the information being
shared so it instantly approved so now
imagine that in you know multiply that
by 10 by 50 by every program you
basically have to go
through something once and repeat it
over and over again simply and easily
the the ability or the impact on bir the
impact on efficiency the impact on
customer experience enormous and the use
cases are are really unlimited so that's
a case in like the in in in Social
Services uh another one would be when
you uh register to
vote at the conclusion of that process
where you've registered you get issued a
uh digital credential with your your
voter registration now imagine
when it's comes time to vote in a
primary or a referendum or an election
you open up your mobile voting app um
which is going to verify that you are
you by way of your uh Board of Elections
credential and now you can vote from
your phone in a way that is identifi
yeah that that secures your identity um
yeah that's so these are Big Ideas and
this is not Science Fiction it's it's
happening right now this is the future
all of us wonder why we're not
living it's like why can't you talk to
the other system um and and what you're
doing is you're actually saying look I'm
not going to force these systems to talk
to each other what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make it so that any data
that you provided to one actor it could
be your data and then you can also just
be like here you go to to to to someone
else um and so you're not even putting
onus on these other institutions whether
it's a doctor's office or a state agency
or the food stamp agency all they need
to do is be able to give it back to you
in uh this I'm imagining it is something
of like a lock box and then you can open
the lock box up for others uh if if you
want um this would be a dream for a lot
of people would actually would save
lives in a lot of these situations or
keep people off the street or whatnot so
how does it technically work like what
what are you doing to be able to assure
someone that that one like you said hey
that this data is um real and not
tampered with and two that it's secure
okay so great question and essential one
to to have to answer and let me start by
saying this this is not what we do is
not all about Ultra past so as I
mentioned earlier um you know as a
public benefit Corporation with a
mission to simplify Civic engagement you
know we care deeply about making lives
better for people
um that's one two we haven't invented
this whole thing and it's like come
inside the ultra pass tent and stay
there forever because we know what we're
doing not at all I'm as skeptical of of
of big Tech is as as the next person um
we are standing on the shoulders of
others who have created this entire
ecosystem of
Technology those shoulders are groups
like um the Department of Homeland
Security um what's happening in Europe
with gdpr so the technology that we use
is something called verifiable
credentials we don't own it we don't we
didn't invent it verifiable credentials
are that is that tamperproof digital
credential that contains your private
information called
claims the standards around a credential
have been debated fought over argued
about for years and years and years by
other people again these are the
shoulders that we're standing on so now
we have these Global standards on what
is a digital verifiable credential what
does it have to look like in order for
it to be used all over them in various
places and the security of those
credentials again not us we that's not
what we've developed what we've
developed is making it easy for issuers
to issue credentials to holders for
holders to hold them and for holders to
to share them so we're standing on the
shoulders of others um this ecosystem
has been developing over the last 10
years and it's reached now this Tipping
Point where it's beginning to show up in
your daily lives everywhere um we
started in 2020 working with Microsoft
in a private preview of verifiable
credentials now you may have used that
product that has subsequently been
developed by Microsoft it's called
Microsoft entra
ID you may have used it if you've ever
verified your um your employment status
in LinkedIn LinkedIn now has this
verified ID component that's based on
verifiable credentials the Department of
Homeland Security in the United States
is going to be issuing uh say green
cards using verifiable credentials
using a particular standard that we work
in the same standard so if department of
hland security issues as a green card
our issuers and verifiers can consume
that green card from that holder it's
completely open standard um the security
baked into these things is robust you're
not relying on Ultra pass but you're
relying on This Global cons Consortium
of public and private um participants
that are sec making sure that your
privacy is preserved and that security
is is is raised to a level that right
now we we cannot do so it's a lot of fun
what we're involved with there's a lot
going on right now wow so so there's
been a global standard that's developed
it's just that uh it's not being
utilized by a lot of either consumers or
institutions is that the description
yeah so ad do so we sit at the we we sit
at the tip of the spear we that adoption
company we're the application layer that
goes in and says okay technolog is here
now everybody let's go use it again I'll
use that Shopify example right you could
have used been you could have built a
e-commerce site on your website but you
know what's a shopping cart how do I
build a shopping cart I don't know how
to build a shopping cart so Shopify
comes in says no no just put this in and
now you have it all that's what we do
and without making it easy for issuers
and verifiers and holders to to engage
it doesn't engage so you have to build
all the standards and then you've got
companies like Ultra pass that come in
and going say okay now we're going to
make it easy for people to actually
engage with this technology wow so you
guys are essentially like an open system
you you're not trying to keep anyone in
you're just like look guys here the
tools and come to ultra pass and use
these tools and and then you're going to
have all these benefits but there's
nothing keeping anyone from doing it
elsewhere it's just that your
uh one of the company one of the only
companies I know of um that's offering
this in part because I I think you guys
just actually want to improve people's
lives and solve the problem is that a
reasonable description yeah um and again
I'm I'm grateful for all the work that
other people have done in this space
because without it we couldn't do what
we do um but we we don't get caught up
in a lot of the debate over what is the
right standard that's not what we do do
and there are a number of different
standards that have uh that exist today
for your listeners that maybe have a
mobile driver's license on their phone
that was issued by a state uh Louisiana
for instance that is a verifiable
credential of a particular standard the
uh credential being issued by yeah this
this digital green card that's going to
be issued by Department of Homeland
Security that uh is going to be of a
different standard called the w3c
standard uh what Ultra pass does is we
don't really care what standard is used
we just want to make it easy for them to
be issued held and and shared and and
that's that's the application layer
that's how we simplify this verified
data
exchange hey YouTube glad you're
enjoying the podcast if you really like
it hit subscribe and then YouTube will
notify you every time we have a bang up
new guests thank
you that's really clever so if you were
to U forecast a a future let let's say
that I'm listening to this and I'm
thinking like ooh um is this something I
can sign up for will this improve my
life like what kind of adoption are we
looking for I like when you talk about
the examples
um I think um that it might be different
institutions like healthcare providers
or insurance companies but I is there a
place for a consumer who's like hey I'd
like to stop having to rovide my data
everywhere I go um I my I'll tell you my
personal thing is that the password
protocols uh have changed so much that
like you can't even have one password
anymore um you have to have multiple
passwords and then um and then everyone
once in a while you get a message from
one of your companies being like hey you
might want to change that password and
you're like oh
no like um is this forecasting uh Noto
distant future where I can just show up
and doors magically open for me and I'm
just like Ultra pass and then uh and
then Bar's like yeah we know you're you
yes um again it's not a technology
problem um it's just it's an adoption
challenge um we've you've
your listeners may have heard of like
passwordless like what does that even
mean like I don't need a password
anymore so we there's a there's a couple
of ways that we work with that so part
of what we do is Biometrics is basically
registering your face oh um now that my
face is my ultra pass your face is your
username and password um
now if I'm one of your listeners my eyes
are rolling saying buyas
and and privacy that's no that's not
what I'm thinking I mean I I'm just
thinking you know I've got a face and
it's I mean it's hard for uh a scammer I
think to just like you know fake my
face uh it's actually not what's
difficult is to fake liveness liveness
would be I mean you may have done it
where you you know move your head around
and it's in the little yeah yeah that's
what I meant I mean you know liveness is
hard uh deep fakes are pretty easy right
so private so yeah um identity
verification uh is a big part of what we
do um again we work with other companies
so it's not all about Ultra pass but
when it comes to facial recognition um I
don't I don't want my Biometrics
floating around the internet um so um
one of the the solution that we work
with it leverages something called
homomorphic encryption which is really
cool
that's a funky word but it's really cool
basically your your Biometrics are taken
on your device and then it's using
encryption it basically removes all of
the any anything private about you and
converts it down to zeros and ones and
basically that those zeros and ones are
then um uh create your biometric makeup
and then when you come back in uh and
you use your face again it converts it
to zeros and ones and compares those
zeros and ones to the to the original
registered zeros and ones and it matches
no private information ever leaves your
phone so wow what does that mean it's
not even comp it's not compliant with
gdpr in Europe it's not even subject to
gdpr because no private information ever
leaves your device wow now that those
Biometrics are also you know it's it's
bias free the
whole machine learning that had been
done was basically this is really
another cool thing check this out so you
know how AI Works in machine learning
and you need millions and millions of of
inputs in order to to build the the the
AI so um did you know that facial
recognition systems were really built
using public images mostly of like
famous people like I didn't know that um
then there then companies came around
and said all right one that's not really
great for the images of people who were
using without them knowing um but two
you know famous people are all like kind
of look alike like there's so what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
random set of images of fake people like
a billion of them and then we're going
to teach we're going to train AI on
facial recognition on billions of fake
images and that's how they have trained
the AI so now you don't have any bias
because you can just create billions of
faces have all different kinds and um
and the AI can pick up on on on the
components of a of your unique face
compared to this like huge data data U
inputs of of fake people so anyway so
there's there's
Biometrics use your face log in with
your your your phone or your camera on
your um on your computer now what
happens is your Biometrics are linked to
it in one way we do things is your
Biometrics are actually linked to your
username and password at this like
website so they have an account in their
system yeah that is still subject to
being penetrated by Bad actors those are
not we you don't we don't have to make
all that go away day one yeah but if
there's a username and password in the
back end or an account for Andrew Yang
you can link that to your biometric and
it links that to your face so now
instead of having to put in your
username and password you just look at
the camera and it says oh is this and
done if a listener is like oo this is a
future I want to uh be a part of uh what
can they do and are there particular
types of customers or institutions that
you're more excited to hear from uh yes
so our traction is really
in mostly in government um so we're
working with local state federal
governments uh around the world uh so if
I if I was like a local government
um and I wanted to make life easier for
my uh constituents then I could sign up
with ultra pass and then what would
happen yes so we would work with their
uh with the IT department it's a simple
little web hook into their systems what
we can't help and we can't help local
governments if their data is in file
cabinets uh or in some Mainframe from
1985 uh so there really needs to be a
level of mature
um Within These different um uh
different potential customers uh the
good news is that's happened really for
most of them most of them are past that
curve you got local governments as one
you've got corporates as another and
then you got
individuals so right now we're not
targeting individuals at all in order to
drive adoption it's really about getting
issuers and verifiers the holders will
come the individuals will come um
because it's going to either get them
money or just make their life better oh
I don't have to go for an appointment I
can just do it for my
phone we're not worried about driving
adoption with the individual we are
focused on the issuer and verifier like
click here to get your money people are
going to click it's working with the
government to say to to tie them into
our technology is is is where we're
focusing our our efforts on on building
customer base it's Banks it's a uh
electronic medical records companies
we've had a lot of conversations we're
working on a big thing right now in
health insurance um over uh different
part of the world uh in the banking
where open banking we have here in the
US and I don't know if you've ever if
you're a business owner and you ever had
to um you know you want to log into your
account and see your balance you can do
that fine no no problem but if you ever
wanted to like wire out money you may
end up having to get a phone call from
some call sender confirming that you
just put that in now that happens a lot
uh because the bank wants to raise the
identity Assurance level that oh this is
really the person who wants to send
money out um that level of friction is
terrible because you know the person
that's trying to do it might not be able
to answer the phone and then they have
to call back and it's a call center and
they don't doesn't work so we remove
that process by using um using Ultra
pass for identity verification and
identity and Assurance levels so finance
companies healthcare companies um
obviously state federal local
governments uh anybody that has had some
sort of data breach um and needs to
address those concerns um a lot of what
we do can what we do can solve a lot of
these problems and it's all win-win it's
it's affordable it imp improves customer
experience it provides agency to the
customer to control their data and it
raises the bar in security to levels
that here to four we haven't been able
to deliver yeah really it it gets the
burden off of that institution in some
ways it's like hey now now you've got it
it's like a data passport and after I
give you the data passport uh then you
can go take it wherever and has nothing
to do with me and that's a win for me
it'll make you feel better about me but
it'll also mean less calls to my
office yeah no the reusability is is
enormous
you know that's the frustration that we
save for people it's like I only have to
do this once and I can just share it
where I want to share it it's it's it
this is going to change how people
businesses and governments engage with
one another uh it is not a question of
will this happen it's just a question of
how fast does it happen and we're trying
to move as quickly as we can to gain
adoption around the
world
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for
three months it will keep you cool don't
just take my word for it my kids seek
out this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts now
[Music]
yeah man I mean you you're going to
improve lives and probably save lives at
the margins thank you and congrats for
spending three years um making that
tweet about a citizen portal happen in
real life for those of you who are
listening why haven't you spent three
years making one of my tweets real what
the hell's wrong with you look at Eric
he's going to change the world um Andrew
you're my source of all information
anything I do I do because you've s you
told me to do it no that's so so let's
close on your Iowa story because I'm
sure people would would love to hear it
okay thank you for coming back to that
so um democracy is amazing it's amazing
form of government um caucuses are the
most undemocratic thing I've ever
seen
so I'll set the stage it's
February
2020 it's dark out it's in the evening
I'm at I'm in the basement of a church
and I am the caucus captain or whatever
Precinct Captain for Andrew Yang and I
show up and there are Precinct captains
from the various candidates um in the
basement and then the Iowa citiz show up
and they move to the corner of the room
where the precinct Captain is standing
and event and what happens is the people
run in the caucus go and count how many
people are in each corner of the room
great as I'm watching this unfold I see
this young woman she's in her
30s and there are two Precinct captains
on either side of
her and I don't remember remember the
candidates who they were
representing but one was telling her how
she should come to his side of the room
because he's coached her kids and he
knew her he knows her parents and she
should come over to her his side of the
room other person was saying no no no
you should come to my side of the room
because my daughter babysits for your
kids you know we go to the same church
you should come to my side of the room
and this poor woman is crying because
she doesn't know what to do and is being
bullied by
pre and I'm s it's it's you know it's
horrible right and I'm sitting there
watching this unfold one my heart's
breaking here's this woman obviously has
young kids at home it's night time it's
cold out she came here to do her civic
responsibility
only to be bullied by people in C so
this is I was watching this saying these
have to go away these have to go away
not to mention I'm in the hotel and I'm
you know in there in in the elevator and
there's a woman who works at the hotel
and I'm like are you voting in the
caucus she go I can't vote I'm working
yep yeah it's
like caucuses
are maybe there was a time and a place I
don't know what that looked like um but
the idea aidea that bullying is part of
the strategy is terrible I was so I
don't get angry a lot I try not to find
I try not to but I was really I felt
really bad for that woman that was
crying um I just wanted to make that
pain go away right just leave her alone
let her decide I mean let her do what
she wants to do not because you're
forcing her to do it anyway that was my
experience I hadn't heard stories like
that I'm sure there are many but I
thought your your listeners might find
that interesting informative and
horrifying all at the same time and why
we need to evolve and imagine imagine
Andrew the adop the the engagement we
would have in primaries and referendums
and elections if people can do it safely
securely privacy privacy preserving from
their own uh home from their own device
and that is that's been my North Star
for many many many many years yeah
voting on your phone uh is the dream and
it sounds like Ultra pass is going to
help hasten that dream into reality I'll
tell you a lot of Americans think okay
wait a minute at this point I'm running
my life uh my
finances um my really like private uh
data on my phone but then when it's
voting time I'm driving to the local uh
high school or Center I'm standing in
line um like it's like a trip backwards
in time um and people realize on some
level that it's in in large part because
the powers that be don't actually want a
lot of us to vote uh you know like that
hotel worker who's who's not able to
participate in the caucus if they really
wanted to they could make a process
where she could vote but they don't care
you know and like that like there
there's like a certain layer
uh of folks who are benefiting from the
current system uh and if we modernize
that process then you change uh the
calculation and people are going to
fight that but in in my opinion uh it's
going to improve things dramatically and
it sounds like alra pass is going to be
part of making it happen yeah I look as
I said I want to I look through the
world through the lens of of a problem
solver and there are those that I guess
don't want people to vote I'm I'm sure
there are people I know there are people
that that like the status quo to
preserve their own power I understand
that it is my problem but that's not
what I'm Sol I if we just Empower people
um by providing them the solutions that
they could use um to engage then I know
we're on the right side of History
because it's going to happen um and
that's why you know working with with
you and forward party and our friends at
Mobil voting.org with Joselyn bakaro
what they're doing the opportunity to
not just talk about these Solutions but
to actually go out and make them happen
for voters uh today tomorrow in the
immediate future uh is what we're all
about is making things real not just
talking about them but delivering
providing the solutions to organizations
and individuals um to really help
improve their lives so mobile voting is
something that's been really close to my
heart for really before we even started
Ultra pass and um we're going to bring
that to fruition uh soon uh with uh with
help of of others like yourself who care
deeply for it as well so there's a lot
of U lot of good stuff coming for people
um and we're just excited to be a part
of it and by the way for people that
want to find me you can go to ultra pass
id.com you can follow me on X Twitter I
don't really do too much on that but at
ericd Star uh I do I do monitor my
LinkedIn a lot more so you can find me
there as well U please reach out this
man at Eric star it's two RS it is thank
you well you're building it you're the
real thing Eric so excited for Ultra
pass making it so that um people's data
actually can be theirs for the the
transport anytime they want as opposed
to relying upon some faceless org to
maybe send another faceless or your
information so maybe you can get
whatever you're probably entitled to you
know certainly if it's a a government uh
congratulations and uh we'll we'll keep
track of ultra passes development every
step of the way really excited for you
and thank you on a personal level for
everything you've
done uh for me the
campaigns uh Venture for America forward
and the future and sure you've always
been an inspiration to me so I'm just
I'm just I'm I'm happy to be your friend
I I I love you you know that brother oh
man I love you too
Eric